you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played today March
31st at Greg chess 2018 round 1 game on
the white end
Fabiano Caruana he's paired against
Magnus Carlsen as most of you probably
already know these two will be competing
later this year from November in the
World Chess Championship that will be a
best-of 12 game match let's see what
words they would have to share with one
another on the board before that big
event Caruana opening with d form let's
see what defense we would have in this
game
Kings Indian defense with the knight on
c6 black is preparing e5 so white
interferes with this grabbing some space
a new home now needs to be found b4 it
is that short-lived Knight a six and
ideally you know if white wants to kill
off this knight entirely you'd like to
construct a 3 and B 4 taking away the
strong square c5 but that would leave
white tactically vulnerable the B form
of c3 Knight would be hanging and the
bishop would be unleashed with Knight
takes d5 so in the game it's Knight d4
white says you know what your knight is
strong in the center I'm gonna give him
a kick d5 what is white do here couple
choices move the knight or capture the
pawn computer likes moving the Knight to
b3 maintaining the strong pawn on d5 and
having an eye on Knight a5 putting
pressure on the Queen side in this game
there's a capture D takes c6 on pass on
recapture with the pond so with this
there's a change in the structure 2 to 1
majority tipping in blacks favor these
guys are set back some but it's still a
majority and it can get rolling and does
get rolling
castles e5 the night will have to move
now
Knight b3 in the game computer prefers
keeping it in the key 16 squares Knight
b3 is however watching over the c5
square the game follows with c6 this is
a multi-purpose move for one control d5
and to provide a new square to a bad
piece knight on a six is a bad piece but
in just a few Tempe will be morphed into
a best piece there's now a new square on
c7 and well we'll see where he goes from
there
notice the
quark times
about 77 minutes for Caruana until move
13 deform this move took nearly a half
hour this is a sign Caruana is not
comfortable with his position and these
past few decisions and I believe it's
related to the night on b3 why am i
drawing attention to the night on b3
notice the domino effect it has on
White's queenside night on b3 means
there will be no b4 and if there's no b4
there will be no possibility to
fianchetto so what are you to do as
white with the Queen Bishop God opened
his eyes in some way efore it is there's
an additional idea behind this move
let's see what that is
Knight c7 F for creating a pawn duo and
white looks to step foot in blacks house
96 follows f5 Knight d4 let's pause for
a moment this night has been quite the
traveller
and now is a best piece and
unfortunately for white
why can't capture the night straightaway
so has to kind of work around the night
or put pressure on the d4 square this is
what we have Knight e3 in the game
trying to take twice on d4 in this
position is not a good idea because of
Knight g4 capture a threat against the
Queen
this diagonal is vulnerable dark squares
are under black's control possibilities
for Queen b6 with check may be Queen to
h4 this is little investment for a
wonderful piece play for black and this
pawn investment is probably just
short-lived lack is very close to simply
winning it back f5 is hit a million
times short story capturing twice on d4
no good you would subject yourself to a
lot of dark square pressure in the game
it's Bishop e3 preparing to simply
recapture on d4 with the bishop and now
we have at this stage Carlsen basically
and dictating play Caruana is the one
who is having to react for these next
several moves so we have Knight takes
Bishop that is the bad bishop that the
knight just took out but it is still a
bishop in this position is soon to be
cracked open for blacks Bishop pair
- to recapture another capture on a5
white is recapturing with upon it is now
past but at the same time
white is capturing away from the center
and black now has a central majority 2
to 0 this majority gets rolling d5 hits
CD CD rook a to d1 d for continuing to
push the majority there aren't many ways
to get out of this fork Bishop g5 black
can not take the knight just yet
so first addresses the pin now two
Knights are under fire white saves one
with check and only then the other night
a4 counterpunch black hits back though
the Queen is unprotected black give some
direction with Queen c7 Queens are
exchanged white still has to react here
there is no
you know there isn't some direct threat
right now but the this night is very
close the night on a four is very close
to being completely dead be six and
where do you go night all the squares
would be taken away so it has to be very
timely here night a to see 5 B six
follows and now Bishop takes Knight so a
decision here for black how do you want
to you know what kind of minor piece
endgame do you want to work with do you
recapture here and play with two bishops
versus two knights or do you build up
some more in the center build up your
central pawn mass and play a Bishop
versus Knight position black chooses the
latter capturing on c5 so as an example
if Bishop takes Bishop we'd have two
Knights versus two bishops the Knights
are ideal you know a knight on e4 a very
good block hater and it would help
support a king side pawn advance
controlling g5 + f6 so be a strong piece
that can be reinforced as well so in the
game it's B takes e5 Bishop takes Bishop
King takes Bishop and now Knight to d2
computer's preferring some pressure here
trying to provoke c4 and then
repositioning the knight in the game
it's an immediate reposition Knight to
d2 notice black has wonderful harmony
structure on dark light square bishop
they work well together Bishop d7 f6
check King f8
have to get a square for the night efore
des rook to e8 94 miners are now gone
and if we just do a piece bike piece
comparison the white rooks not very well
placed the black rooks on the other hand
are ideally placed behind the past pawns
and they certainly have the flexibility
to shift some gears and we will see this
shortly targeting be two rooks not the
best block haters the King needs to help
out soon c4 in the game G for each side
trying to get the majorities rollin
creating past pawns
rook to b8 rook takes e5 rook takes b2
to passers for black connected14 white
white still has a lot more work to do
before a second pass pawn is created
rook to D 5 D excuse e3 and you can't
take this pawn on d4
rip to DA what's the issue with rook
takes d4 well c2 how you stopping the
punt Rick c1 doesn't do it rook b1 so
what is tried is rook to d8 check only
move and now rook h8 so there's the
threat of not only winning the pawn but
the rook and black now has to be very
careful so for example if the King goes
to e6 there would be a check and the
best that black could do from there
simply return to have 7 and if the black
and if the black king in this position
goes to g6
this would be a win for white with rook
g8 King here rook g7 in King here
it's a checkmate in six it's at this
point why could simply forget about this
little pawn race and say you know what
what are you doing - stop rook age five
white would be winning if the King goes
here in this position so what does
Carlsen do doubles up on the seventh
ranked defends against the skewer gives
up the h7 pawn this is what we have rook
takes h7 King g6 a pair of rooks are off
black is down upon but what's most
important here is the quality of the
pawns notice how close the black pawns
are to promoting five tempi away from
producing two queens white is much
further off from having similar in the
game we have King f - C - this is much
better than capturing the pawn capturing
the pawn would allow a discovered check
and the king would get here which is
preferable to what happens in the game
let's see what this is see two forces
the rook to blockade d3 King III and
rook here threatening to push through
the King has to now blockade on d2 not
d3 so
he's further back in white now has the
responsibility to stop this promotion
King takes pawn only at this stage
material is balanced so close to
promoting and these guys here are still
a long ways off but given time why would
like to advance them and this is what we
have h4 right now King e5 rook to f1
it's very important that white be in a
position to shoo the King away as soon
as it as soon as the King defends this
pawn otherwise there'll be a an idea to
get to the e2 square so for example if
white doesn't try to reposition the rook
here and says you know what this guy's
past let's push them and let's push them
again now you're staring at these ideas
in fact this is a mate on this mate on
the spot threat wrote to e2 big problem
for team white and it's related to this
strong King position on d4 so we have
rook to f1 King to d4 and now h5 you
don't have to give check just yet
because this rook isn't threatening
anything
to e2 is not a threat just yet h5 in the
game this isn't one of those well I have
two passers they're both on the same
rank let's flip a coin and we'll move
one of them no if you move the g5 pawn
you're in big trouble because there's a
clear idea that black would have in
reply to g5 how do you know that it
should be this pawn that advances well
notice the promotion squares which one
is going to promote and give check HD
pawn is the winner this matters this
difference which pawn promoting to give
check this matters let's see why if in
the game g5 is played the clear path to
victory for Team black is to play - b7
b1 and what is white doing capture the
rook I mean if you capture the rook it's
just a promotion going here allows a
rook capture and you're going to get
mated and if you ignore this threat
altogether and just push the pawn rook
takes rook Queen without check and you
end up getting mated
the difference here with h5 the move in
the game
if now rook b7 h6 rook b1 here here aha
you don't have time to promote and give
me because you're in check
this position interestingly enough would
actually be a drop even though white has
a queen there would be no way for white
to let's say win this pawn with check or
give some fork to the King and win the
rook black has a threat of his own at
this stage to promote
so this is the pond to advance because
of this promotion idea with check with
rook d7 in the game we now have rook F
for this is very important
rook F 2 is simply not a defense here in
the game it's rook f4 of rook F 2 the
rook would still come in and give check
and you're not stopping both pawns rook
F 4 in the game King goes back notice
this is the first time we have this
position the rook now returns defending
this promotion and threatening the pawn
black King steps up rook returns to f4
check King back to d5 second instance of
this exact position the rook returns to
f1 King c-4 once more
rook f4 and now if the King goes here
that would be the third time and that
would be a draw by repetition of
position and this is not what we have so
sending some message maybe for this
later match in November I'm here to play
ball King to b3
Carlson is still trying to press here
and rightly so quality of the pawns this
is very dangerous for team white rook b4
in the game King takes a three rook c4
King b3 and rook c8 let's just pause for
a moment this is move 54 this game is
over in five moves this is a very
interesting
endgame I'm only scratching the surface
with these next couple variations I
share with you but yeah this is a
critical moment in the game in the game
we have a 5 but the star move here
surprisingly enough is the move
well I'll throw it to you I haven't
thrown a pop quiz your way in this video
if you'd like to spot this star move on
black side feel free to pause the video
and work it out ok the best move here a
winning move is look to h7 what does
this move doing it freezes both pawns
neither can now move without the H pawn
dropping and in the meantime this extra
pawn that black has can now get rolling
riki each seven was not played in the
game well let's see what would happen if
it was first suppose white replies with
some checks and then gets back over like
this now this a pawn could run the King
could take here but if the King takes
there there's King b1 and there's not a
good way to defend against this pawn
from promoting there could be some a
couple checks like this but if you ever
capture the rook would soon be picked up
that's one very quick variation and the
other one is one that Carlsen would have
needed to calculate accurately over ten
moves deep let's say white moves in
black moves yeah ten moves let's just
say so
what is this interesting line rook h7
star move you would have he would have
had to spot another star move some 10
moves later suppose King takes pawn in
this position white could do this but
notice you know White's winning upon but
at the same time that pond was
sheltering they came from some checks on
the D file black would be able to come
over and give check and now end up
winning this pawn race a v h6 a form
can't go here just yet g5 a3 g6 it's at
this point black would have to find
another star move keep in mind white is
ready to advance with what pawn which
one would you like to as white advance
to are advanced with at this stage the
Jeep on as that would would be the one
that would promote with check in this
case black would have the star move
there's only one winning move here for
black the rook basically cannot stop the
pawns from successfully getting to the
seventh rank but this additional star
move rook to d8 is the winning move some
again
10 moves later trying to deflect the
rook rook takes rook black would promote
and if white just goes here now we would
have a 2 because in the end this is not
a threat the rook is there to stop the
promotion with check black would be
winning this pawn race but would need to
find this star move and then in the
event of a king takes pawn this later in
our rook d7 in rook d8 move didn't come
up with it in the game a5 instead and
now this one ends in just five moves
Czech King takes pawn the rook gets
behind and black actually has to be a
little bit careful these pawns are
really moving fast and it's at this
point that black goes ahead and gives
multiple checks and this one ends
peacefully players agreeing to a draw
you can't really try to just keep
running with a pawn like this just as an
example there's a check could even give
up the rook once these two pawns are on
the sixth rank there's no stopping a
successful promotion in this pawn isn't
going to be fast enough to get a queen
this would read this would be a drawn
position but there's no reason to even
go for something like that it's much
easier to keep giving checks and keeping
the rook around behind this past pawn so
it ends peacefully here but certainly a
fighting draw and if this is a preview
of what's to come come November I think
we're in for a wonderful World Chess
Championship match
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe even took a thing or two away from
it that's all for now take care bye
you